On Capitol Hill, where
at this hour,
the CEO of Norfolk
Southern is testifying
before a Senate committee.
Alan Shore has been facing
tough questions really for weeks
Over the railroads,
the rail company's safety practi
in the wake
of last month's toxic train dera
in his palace in Ohio.
And now he has some explaining t
before Congress.
Shaw has apologized
more than once for the derailmen
and he also says that
his company is making changes
and will do right
by the people of Palestine.
Let's get straight to Sunlen Ser
who's watching
this very important testimony on
from from Washington right now.
Sunlen, what have you heard so f
Well, certainly, Kate,
there was a sense of frustration
among many in the panel
for the residents of East Palest
But we did just hear
from the CEO of Norfolk
Southern, of course, the company
and the person specifically that
had so much criticism
in the aftermath
of this train derailment.
And we heard from Mr.
Shaw.
He said he is deeply
sorry of what happened
and he promised to see this thro
to get it right for the resident
And he said point blank,
it was clear
safety mechanisms that we had in
were not enough.
Here's more of what he had to sa
I am determined
to make this right
Norfolk Southern cleaned the sit
thoroughly and with urgency.
You have my personal commitment
Norfolk Southern will get the jo
and help East Palestine thrive.
Now, in the lead up to this hear
The company has
released
a slew of new safety requirement
and they are regularly
essentially self-regulating
in the aftermath of this derailm
Money invested into the communit
to help with the cleanup.
More resources on the ground.
So they've made plenty of promis
But for many,
of course, in the community
and many on Capitol Hill,
this simply is not enough.
And we heard from the two senato
from Ohio today,
a Republican and a Democrat,
and they have a bipartisan piece
of legislation
that they are pushing forward
to put more strict regulations
in the railroad industry.
This is something that they talk
at length,
say that the people of East Pale
deserve this
And they specifically called on
to publicly endorse
this legislation today.
That is something that he did no
during his opening statements.
But as is ongoing hearing contin
perhaps he most likely will be a
if he endorses
that piece of legislation Kate.
All right.
John King is going to continue t
this hearing for us.
I appreciate it, Sunlen.
Jason Carroll is live in East
Palestine, Ohio, right now.
Jason is in Norfolk,
Southern speaks to Congress.
What are people there saying
about the support of the rail co
Well, look, there is
obviously a great deal of concer
on the ground from residents
concerned about the air quality,
the water quality, the soil qual
It's not just
about the environmental impact
and safety.
It's also about the economic imp
And we've been speaking to peopl
who worry about their property
values, worry about their busine
This business
that you see behind me, Kate,
you see all these blue
container containers,
these containers are used
to hold hazardous materials.
This factory here is located act
right next to the derailment sit
This factory owner says his work
so uncomfortable being here
that they don't feel like
they can safely work here.
So this factory
for at least a short time
has basically all but shut down.
So that's what he's dealing with
Also, spoke to a woman
who runs a hair shop here in tow
and she has lost 50% of her busi
She had a specific message to Al
Listen to what she had to say.
I think just make it right.
You got to get emotional.
But this is my income.
And so I raised my family
just to help us.
I got any help
I don't want Norfolk Southern to
Take this from me.
So the question for a lot of fol
here, Kate, is
how do you make homeowners whole
How do you make businesses
whole after something like
this has happened to Alan Shore?
In his opening
statements,
there has said
that he will be here in this com
Norfolk, Southern, Southern,
as long as it takes.
And a lot of people just aren't
sure that will that will happen
They are concerned about their f
And so as we listen to more abou
Alan Shore says during his testi
a lot of folks are going to be l
in to see
about what specifics
are going to be laid out
in terms of the long term econom
for people here in East Palestin
Kate. Jason, thank you.
Joining me now for more on
this is Sarah Feinberg.
She's the former acting administ
of the Federal Railroad Administ
It's good to see you there.
Thank you for coming in.
I know you were listening in to
hearing as it was getting underw
as well.
We've heard
when we heard
what we heard from Alan Shore.
Similar to what we've heard befo
He laid out an explanation
and in an opinion piece
ahead of the hearing,
what do you think of what he's s
His explanation
Do you think this rail company
that Norfolk Southern can,
of course, correct enough on its
Well, look, he's
saying all the right things now.
And any railroad can say
all the right things now.
You're, you know,
four or five weeks
after a tragic derailment
that's gotten an enormous amount
attention, an enormous amount
of congressional attention,
certainly in the hot seat right
So I'm not surprised
we're hearing
all the right things from him no
It'll be what happens in the fut
What are they saying?
Where are they doing
three months from now,
six months from now?
And not just Norfolk Southern,
but the entire rail industry
and not just back.
What is Congress doing?
How are they reacting?
I was going to ask you
about that because they're
it's it's
it's probably never
is easy to say
is blame lands in one place.
But where do you see it as?
Because I was kind of like
who really dropped the ball?
Is it the company?
Is it the administration?
Is it Congress?
So the reality is, is certainly
the railroad is accountable
and certainly
they should be held accountable.
But the industry as a whole
has thought
everything, even common sense,
safety, regulation, tooth and na
for as long as anyone can rememb
So this doesn't just go back
a couple of years.
This goes back decades.
And so when you have
an incredibly powerful industry
that will fight a safety
regulator tooth and nail,
it becomes really difficult to b
to get the kind of regulations d
that you need to.
And then they have a Congress
that they can go to
that is often
very friendly to them,
particularly Republicans,
but it can be on both sides.
And so once the safety regulator
actually works,
they go to the Congress
and they water it down the compa
They've announced changes will c
And if we need to fix it,
we're having an audio issue
and we're going to fix it
at the very same time, don't wor
So we're going to fix it
as I as we continue speaking.
The company has announced change
we've got they've announced chan
They've kind of laid out what th
they're going to do.
Going forward,
we've now we as Jason and Sunlen
we're talking about,
there's a bipartisan bill
that they're pushing in Congress
It gets there's a lot of things
that they're talking about impro
or more
heat detectors on the rails
and stiffer fines for violations
and so on and so forth.
From your view
and what you've seen
in terms of regulation
that's been put on the table
and not implemented?
Is there one thing
that must happen
in order to improve safety?
I mean, if there's one thing
that has to happen in order
to improve safety, it's
to give the safety regulator
more authority
It's to fix the regulatory proce
which is completely broken
and has been for years.
That's not a Biden thing.
That's not even a Trump thing.
That's not an Obama thing
that is going back
all the way to Nixon and Johnson
So that's the kind of issue
that if you're
going to fix the entire thing,
give the safety regulator more a
You know,
I heard some of these senators
say at the top of the hearing,
you know, safety is our top prio
Alan Shore says safety is my top
priority, actually.
The only person who's really pri
safety is going to be
the safety regulator
are those empty words that you'r
from members of Congress then.
And the company looks
not on the other side
of this as profit yet.
Not not all of them.
There are some members of Congre
who have been on the side of saf
for as long as I can remember.
But there are some members,
some members of the Senate that
speaking this morning
were pushing back on regulators,
pushing back
on the administration's saying,
where were you?
Those are the same senators
who fought regulations for years
I mean, when I was the federal r
administrator several years ago,
we tried to do a breaking regula
The Congress watered it down.
We got it done.
So it'll be important
to hold these members of Congres
accountable to it
just in the immediate right,
because a lot of this
is going to take time.
It's going to take political wil
And we all know where that kind
ends up quite often.
But this things can change.
But it does take time
when you're looking at anything
coming out of Washington
in general from what you've seen
and how close you've been to the
In speaking with the CEOs
of these companies
and everything that you've seen
in terms of regulation.
Do you think the rail, the count
rail systems, rail system is ope
well? Do you.
Is it
operating on a knife's
edge all the time
as it's going through communitie
across the country?
What is there stopping it from?
Is Palestine
happening in Goshen, Indiana,
where I grew up?
Nothing.
Or Charleston, West Virginia,
where I grew up nothing.
The reality is, is the rail
industry is generally safe.
You want to move things,
particularly hazardous materials
not by truck.
That said,
it can be a lot better
and it's not as safe as it could
and it would be safer
if Congress would stop
watering down regulations,
if the industry
didn't fight
every single commonsense safety
regulation tooth and nail
with everything they've got.
We can make it much safer.
Interesting.
It's great to see you, Sarah. Th
It's
such an interesting perspective
that all of us are just starting
to learn more and more about. Th